we are
dear colleagues, madam
president, welcome to the chamber,
i greet you in
this very difficult and delicate moment
for europe and for our citizens,
i hope that you and your families and
loved ones are all in good health
we are experiencing a
unexpected extraordinary situation that has
led us in recent weeks to
take unprecedented decisions
often anticipating the rapid evolution
of circumstances with the aim of
protecting the health of our staff
of deputies and at the same time
guaranteeing the democratic life of
our institution we had to
slow down  of course, but everyone hasn't
stopped and I believe that this is the
most important signal because
democracy cannot be suspended
especially in the midst of such a dramatic crisis
and indeed it is our duty precisely in these
very difficult times to be at the service
of our citizens who are so
suffering give them guidance a
hope for a  Facing this
dark moment and the moments that will come as
legislators we have the means and the
possibility and the duty to be useful
today we are here close albeit far
gathered with this unprecedented format of
the extraordinary European Parliament but
all determined to give our
contribution in the fight against this  pandemic
guaranteeing our
democratic function and the continuity of the work
of the parliament because it is only in this way that
we can render a service to the
people to our communities
to our countries to the health personnel
who are sacrificing themselves in the wards of
our hospitals
throughout Europe a few days ago  this
horrible virus and it has hit us very
closely it has also taken away a young
life a boy who worked right here
with us in the european parliament
dear giancarlo's family goes
our deepest condolences
as well as goes to the families of all the
people who have  lost my life
due to covip 19 I want to address a
thoughts of all the people who
are fighting this virus every day
with courage and determination of the sick people
first of all of the medical personnel
who work tirelessly throughout Europe and a
greeting to all our citizens who,
with their responsible and disciplined behavior,
will be decisive for
to eradicate this pandemic we need
all our strength, all our
energy and collaboration and also a
little patience of course to ensure that
this day of
extraordinary plenary of the parliament, so
particular atypical, can be carried out
serenely because with our
decisions
we could  give oxygen to those who
are currently on the front line
in tackling this emergency
dear colleagues
the agenda contains statements from the
council and the commission
coordinated european response to the co
lead 19 epidemic I remind the honorable Members
for this debate  is not foreseen
are not foreseen the  usual procedures
that we use like which I give us the
blue card I inform you that the
presidency of the council, unable to
participate in our work, has
sent me a written declaration which I
will send to all Members I
welcome the president of
the European commission, Mrs von  der
leyen to whom I give the floor right away thanks
the median of co2 emissions
therefore possible extraordinaire
everything is not affected yes ex cordinar the
buildings leader real we know that
fashion fashion schroeder birondi v o
mac the virus who is open to use buddi
monde  so don joe value not mode
division ii not smiling i can't stop
in a step of the daily routine or
with trevi or our used row
fragility of v misan out of 10 in usa
will of god card them of noble
unimaginable hackers what if less
chaos sweet  tour rave york coach in a while
if you don't vote and kiss kiss
put le mans
by omission and or set they do in italy or
spain from a whole europe  to
anyone for the doses they are married there
when he asked if I was chimet everything
giuseppe stinky less pau stinky venugopal
injured honey colleagues the wainscoting visit
the two suspects
all education bayern julio bolts
everyone is known mutations in de grada
gratitude
the only despite
[Music  ]
[Music]
haslam so many balkans yes from sending scarce
della only to shop info by audi lee
westwood making of opinions but only
[Music]
weekend
no no in cantù
because the crisis the union
history
the idea out of your mania and in the suns
a  action member states
i have a jet streak
web d'una a match fu of members to save
venice days
but come google finance 20 percent of
member states 20 lakers twenty five
member states joint lecce ad edgar news
sensu stay with the demons goggles
fashion exchanges pied produces  france
televisions james murphy
in seven days
fulvio response an unprecedented big bang
back no one is the force two and a
half life 2 years maxence of sex and the
guidelines and green of ca  ni
smith ad est
then bo members
seedorf
we can
matteo also thinkin about day after
shoot off
business events
world of jobs for europe in you need is
now the limits gate to save jobs
the wild life
hawass
smog
code think
android
ansa firenze 1 set struss su  crisis tass
and sexy babe
every nation national hosting come
on there
is a is spent
on the final eight assistance against
but will sell studios or pma own
vinica then astura ves
today it comes from breakthrough backhand it's
not good
justin has nai navi cup
there is a drive
be  nice
cannon zo democrat in en en singh vini
among thieves actes sud 20 sep
ansa indeed sends into crisis
do ata comp mettre en el ex art
amm fil fantin
admonished insight from chris i already wrote
arena outing city awaits
the senses but i will live it
thanks president of  melt it yen
as I told you there should have been
an intervention by the presidency of the
council but they were not able to come to
our meetings the presidency
sent me a statement yes  crypt which I
will send to all the Members
allow me of course
also to greet the Croatian friends who
have been affected by the earthquake
to them is our solidarity with
our friendship and our closeness
now let us listen to the opinion of the
political groups please mr gonzalez pons
for  the group of the popular party on the
thank you for banking congress lo shin
bet things done
the joint procurement personal protective
statement back to the positive steps now we
knit golfo d'oro in the short industry
to fight against column vyver winett
guaranty the free flow of medicines
across  borders winett gloves pensions
and salaries non must be less than we
need to if closure function power pt
call service of physical advance in it
are we launch of industrial production
of medical and with many europe therefore
twin best movie il medical research and
in the fight against  diseases and we
knit 4s of economic impact of the
economic crisis forum
I go  in italy and in spain in france in
muccia on prints pointing to whence this
europe in this time considers itself
to criticize the national sgovernment
on the regional but yes it is
acceptable to criticize the european government
as if the unperforated commission
ambiene the government of quarry 1 of  our
truscia i threw him the rar primero that
the commission is acting malice product
that allows it in the competences ass
the second that no national government
clear appetite nada nada but that
that allows it the competence faced with a
single problem the european member state
gone 20  you are different answer on
mars 50 he will feel the president of the
region with competence without aim how
is the virus headquarters to be ra ancient la
frontera us press jandola yes
european institution and is
examining the solidaridad entreneuse european government is
not wrong the european union
fayè pro-europeanism  of the European national slider es
the world health organization
has dealt with at  virus like that a pandemic a
nurse counts annotate al khums and
planetarium perloz european government it is
negotiating it as if it will be 20
you are different
regional infection including regional infections
then it is the virus and it is closing with italy
and spain in france but we will not be  as
ramayana evolution we don't know if it will be
riwal extends against European spies and
when we are not we will turn tonio the
deep ones
we know it will explode in
east africa next russia and what
consequences to lay out untouched they shoot
under the verdad baits i didn't know what's going
to pass could sprecish keep  present
that the solidaridad plus the demons and the
solidarity that magnana civil king
now goes to be European then contemplate
monstrous different europas there of the
concept that if it was honesty late illia
that they fall cia the partner rises to the landing
in applauding the EMS to
confirm Europe  this parliament must be of
Europe which weighs star confined classroom
the mystical idiom the ball co  n falcon
heene or other europe that fish
and incapable of understanding if this
parliament must not close during the
crisis because the parliament is the house
of hope and my country with less than 50
million inhabitants of vamos martos which
in china which holds in  basis of the million
inhabitants and we are living hell and
my country but cincom the doctor
auxiliary nurses yes staff of street vendors sea
counts breath and my countries are very hospitable and
because of the overflow amy country the patient
coronavirus dies only one family member
that the spheres I know you  will you hear only east
or not it's a war
this is an epidemic lowes doctor doesn't
host the save lorne medal arch of
triumph
the spirit presupposition in healthcare doesn't
host the speech of the blood sweat and
tears
the speed racing sma senses and like pedals
mascari gas like aiming  the respirator
as with the soil
the virus tests will come we can share
his whole european
greens nov amos help another when you
go from nurse ter  mino the
generation that but if it is suffering and the
virus and sla of swords and europe
the virus was when the federation
that nation the post war and detaching
from the generation that with stripes
the european economy was when the
generation that generalist or health care
public and public education and
detaching the generation that the ball
violates democracy and port spain
grace was next to the
del rivo generation the berlin wall and detaching
from the generation car nunzio al franco
the all marco is a favor of the euro the
generation of  europe space esa wing
that is attacking the virus
the least that if me the germans not
under the aegis europe flies stay
when helios the need and that if i
gave m1 to the president to ursula von der
leyen and i end by saying long live europe
thanks honorable gonzalez  pons and now
moreno sanchez has the floor
the group of socialists and democrats
please
thank you president madam president
gentlemen today is a
strange session this room almost empty but
our house of European democracy
as you well said president
continues and will continue its activity at the
service of all European citizens
today we must all adopt the
proposed measures to continue our work
clear risks of films naias  palabras and
not blessed by the group being of its
president respectively of
the Spanish delegation act by las
personas campa di rosell
escritos our mass infero think me changing
exploded wave recovered ont rapid
para que las personas epic the
nursing school kg tambien that remains room
as I fear it since  there was
antonella star of the kidnapping sbal with and we
applaud the health personnel and in the
satisfaction then on fight asean of
football against the world pandemic
opening also around they will give us on the
fair nas that we entered when para que
el to meditate possible life is given on
course  having the maze valera at house and
mass with co  exemplary impact
of tyranny i am the best weapon
compare war to st pandev the only
unidos p with european level coordination
well seremos the
virus recover meuse normal life
markets antonio of our economy this
environment we mention on a strategy
that aims to cope  to the evolution
escalona from dellai for the definition
written memo soi are a first step
for positively involved i with
experience and the future of our
fate of the union we keep a short medium
and wide ceiling thinking exclusively
in the future of africa the
aim is the star  they pull and hoping for a
community response necklace that strengthens
our health system the reserves the
resulting need for material that
guarantees a distribution of
essential food and above all that
they have caught pa mitigate it 7 with the
bad guys of the extraordinary sec smi
that they are adopting  the
government shoots to contain the
candia coffee virus  negative to the
economy b summer and especially in the heat was
very concerned about its use then
we count on a package of the source
which guaranteed the use of
structural funds and the tools available
at this 20 20 because it was
dismembered and dan help with the
necessary flexibility  to the
mass effect reaction to hans the environment nor flies
suspend temporally the
supranational rule time
spyro portuário is quarrying cologia go ghost ground
that holds some remove a forced
economic environment environmental express
in the different to the recruitment out of place
try european the european commission of the
bay for  ensure a breath the
grandmother's faction of stability pre
superstar iai massi words important it is
in his moment that the president lula
says buy compare the
material urgent medical supplies to
fight the pandemic to save you towards
however we need ambitious smas medina
if in particular in materi  a
parable of fiscal policy the national effort spi
guaranteed solidarity goes up to the fair
I would just like to list only peos history that
in consonance with the initiative lanzada
seems president sanchez and pedro sanchez
I'm afraid to write only but
the commission is the approval of a  plan
with 25,000 source shoot fight the
social economic crisis that in the
den 10 9 another deruta that doesn't laugh
canaria traffic in which a smart on the
black black at we claim on europe
marshall of in a common european version
financed with an instrument that has become
common  which contained issues must
bonus
the activation of the European
stability mechanism with a specific line of
credit yes in macro economic conditions
additional fly prints if it
already plans a European century of the
assembly that if it combines with a
European system temporal minimum 30 to
protect  implemented the cabinet is located in
favor is located ad horas and especially
the sector of the field  the fishing
last
enter between smith in his name for
coordination and exchange of
information between the state of my gross
respectful heir fronteras the dressing i
kept going up the styles vernasca
economic and
productive yes for human capital enterprises
now the way we are grateful to mr
president
thank you honorable moreno sanchez and now
the floor for the re new europe group to
honorable rich please
next sunday on the garrison and if you share little
we you experienced hostility the
future knowing how to plan successive epidemics i
will close mix of makeup half
and european ept can on my  he considered
worse unusually and caribbean coins
with more than tonight and the alleged
wealth whole we followed them and from his
dorothy slam vale discord I'm a
tail servant and give it months the supplì a against
piazza moro napoli mine pakhalé
nationalism and linear madness and on the
italian duo  disco dance como of
the toad commission and rapone reports state
thursday we owe a la  sso di a1 ros and
his seed or the proposition
fashion research commission and us digital deliveries
move hard is the display case found half
dvd arid points king of the
fashion system to the sites all alterations to the
portal crows passing between team
netiq box casette pdv  and honest warns
that tosi for I think now inter
all falls or there are terrorists who
have placed themselves in a prosperous tartu bode and it may
be area publication on a poem
or or monza to pull ability to
tackle epidemics or perhaps two security and
thus rainer established  social all
one hundred in third place of de feste and that we will
present trouble to three stable slots and they
like deco with meredith little
i think they exist can say that it transmits
know that it
leaves your [ __ ] business to europe gianassi weight
of the aphorisms of just in the most pope
it will have to be funny thanks to a
regular prying the ba please for the pd group
google the word to her and if you want
design de put and maybe it's better already from
now on more  in moscow the pd emilio caterino
band replacement illustrates himself in a
respectful way and we close cox david in
succession derno two gaps of the
blue blind who took the thing the
commission wants the ignobel i don't pass the
bike but we like beckham amazed e and
vidal o  il pretone discovered means
scoline deals with repute enjoys vii and viii i
sniffed the night fi and v60 of analysis
elisa form and are available bringing
more des homme or sms 6 de minimis l ice
the boom emma to send the hana true
with the work on the estimates  set human tris
lev and miss but it happened to me also to
speak on the barrels repents to the trio that i
could scheme already doses nor with the mic use
i had there ouvert hemodialysis junior open
let never make up stop the mask 2
tests and after necessaire can
pass  jones also to paolo yes wine
vision christ it is said yesterday
junior band style strategy to it it is true that to the
genius on the matter that steps
started on sunday solid plan sheen
also to pablo among the junior ope  n to the
taxman bu border control
leave cost the tv and it's breakfast he
answered 12 chimpa honey and harris and
we took he wants decision
crispal in action of tilt houston of
mutual well people a term beyond way
for her and smartphone
the cliche and  le monte abu dhabi for doses he
had taken the word of solidarity or
bennet on par with skele resistance
the union opened by me go crazy capaldo
maybe a nail and the lectiones hesitates
new wounds of the motus allesita they had fodder
défaillance and way of reality or end of
page and  such a purpose are among the
posts from an emigrant to no draw
arches pc oscillino open and the hub
soft are greece and read on tim name
thai elmo padua national team of sel
primo rice pure suisse and man and
seizures million the shin is  plus
of italy and the force of spain i thirst
health they take fay junior open their
piave in civilization one hundred nexus
immortals the cuts put that you
would be alone and sclerosis to see hangover
of any ad  esione mini objects you
went to brand eiste put with good
in your office had stops priority
the epidemic hideouts of snav and from crude plus being
able to close or the sciacca phases cipa
national was potosi what then of
bibbiano and ave what if you want to
coach  of seeds two already now I mention the
truce security third thanks honorable
keller president for the
green group you have the floor
rc n 6 that the who medical health looks
like that includes inclusive
and economic
[Music]
ansa
dominici final investment decision where
you  no
[Music]
thanks president keller on behalf of
the cr group mr epping please have
the floor
the human groups present
[Music]
thanks president aubry and for the
gue group the word and porsche that
the epidemic friar cesare segre mon ass.  re
su don le travail costa mo denigrates
we know what digital bonus share
colleagues or almost and exits but i know that if from
an economic crisis on jazz lino
rocchi could more nest in the various the
pin and hot solidaire these laszlo godoli
new pence and plates his caravan one of
us hoskins and on it a nice guy terre
des hommes and o with pinocchio with the
trust pads of european spanish emilia and one
of the males the people the mask
protection group a  step marquee
sepede de madrid to a
spanish production and what if you logi depot eduli
born mount www.ad on crisis who
are measures protection center of it all
on rigor pool health care codon nicolita di
sestu which can be said to be one in social
wear was  there but a
long rhythm is born on the salt pans that trust
the bullock women chess bags on a no to the
risk manager yes of gardeners of
this new plan as almost as a bankrupt
film the bay bakool and technical limits
how come the maximum test of simone but i
brought mine and land technician lives
of the males
today face increase who will talk about it at
an age bobo craxi put plus 13 asked
sannite list a burden to manage a
manager and stretched out an exam  tta vera
must cut himself years the definition of
the ku sio claire emphatic with pozzi
hisses louis malicious pillow European silk sees he
wants me to cook he expects
thoroughly and fairly
the epidemic makes mobbing in europe
smiles off while now all of
an elf we'll count hairpins and it's more
renewable ago sarah asked with friends
who knows news next jade was george
fat travail de recco gip measures out of
three we follow i
go to the flag tion classes
stability pact sponsor 24 rivas yesterday
nobody the spirit gave me the taboo
due a good i met
the future bonks are off to the police money
passive neoliberalism
thank you president aubry we have
listened to the assessments of the
political groups now the speakers who have
registered to speak mr de langhe
three minutes for you
we find another thing we fight european clubs
mm edition of the wedding la  tension is
dispersed neo hector and in a
mood a man but a strong risk shiva
by film frame and desig  n of a drive is
that she learns site in sweden design and
control pisa line test with lifegate and
canteens by dea kids and then three sable
thing of course in short, who smells
like petrol road car design thank you
honorable benifei three minutes and 30 for
you
please
poli president von der leyen we
are facing perhaps the most
serious crisis since the second world war
the covip 19 epidemic has spread
with frightening speed and has claimed
thousands of lives in europe and in the
world
first of all i express myself also on behalf of
the party delegation  Democrat to
the European Parliament my closeness to the
sick to the families to all those who
have lost loved ones I
thank the doctors the nurses and
health workers who are
fighting on the front lines
only a few weeks ago in this Chamber
not the Italian MEPs
warned of the seriousness  of what
was happening in italy the first
european country hit the government to
deal with the situation did  had to
introduce ever more rigid measures
asking the population to
collaborate to eradicate the virus
lower the curve of infections measures
considered exaggerated and some but which
were then instead adopted by all
the other European countries
these are measures which however have had
a very high cost for  our
economies that the life and for the life of
thousands of people who in recent
weeks have seen their income
and their freedom reduced I am thinking of
those who have been asked to stay at
home, especially in the world
of tourism trade in the  entrepreneurship
with huge economic losses and
risks for jobs I am thinking of
those who at work instead have to
go beyond the aforementioned medical
health personnel to all those who keep
the country and Europe on their feet in these
difficult weeks the
hauliers the workers those who work
in supermarkets the forces of law and order
for this reason I have signed and
strongly support  the appeal of
the European trade unions because every decision
taken today at the European and national headquarters must
be taken keeping the world of work at the center
the European commission has launched good
measures to provide immediate liquidity
to the countries of the union we will vote for them today
many billions of community funds also
for my country italy and aid for
the european aviation sector
the ecb also introduced an
extremely significant purchase program
750 billion in addition to
previous programs the
stability pact has been suspended we know
now but we need
an extraordinary one in sight  of
reconstruction and therefore an
even greater sharing of costs at
European level as a democratic party we
are fighting to ask for this
European response up to the challenge
as citizens and
organizations are asking for with so many
petition requests in these hours, for example
that of science for democracy  and
humans the call of the
academicsguidat  or from roberto castelli and danieli
nera rites that are collecting
together with many other appeals and
requests from the citizens very many
adhesions
president von der leyen said it well
this is a European crisis not of
individual states and as such
its cost must be faced therefore it must  be
shared together with the Group of
Socialists and Democrats we have
launched an action plan based on 25
proposals in the short and long term
we need to create Eurobonds and introduce a
European unemployment benefit to
outline a temporary
European minimum income scheme on the health front we
need to centralize  at
the community level, research on
vaccines, purchases of
medical equipment, but a
reform of the competences in the
health field of tax rules is now also necessary, demonstrates
theses that are not up to the emergency, as
well as extending the system of
own resources to overcome
the exhausting negotiations  of
member states and to increase funds p  o
respond to the challenges we
face
the Italian president conte the yes
together with president macron to
president sanchez to president costa and
five other heads of state and
government sent a letter to their other
European counterparts addressing many of
these issues
today all together these leaders  will
meet the European parliament must
send them a clear message
face this situation with the
seriousness and determination necessary
as Europeans to fight for a
common cause as the president mario dragons wrote in these hours
bankruptcy you will have
your bankruptcy on your shoulders the
bankruptcy of the whole  our history
represented i conclude from this room
that miracle that just a few
weeks ago
liana segre here reminded us of the
miracle of united
europe let's fight this crisis together as europeans
engaged in a common struggle if
we fail this crisis this emergency will
not give us a  another possibility thanks
thanks  and honorable res 2 minutes for you
please about 7 mystic yes they are good brought
it is said families who placed me a
land full of videomusic team to the
family
the new high for purposes and to all that
under my line via suv or for the
of the op  so mercy the formation and mercy
use or not the commission is added up a
field museum fixed photo of
social economic tsunami i know if dawson
of the only visual agony hyenas are not
sold if via seven sisters you pass 70
european marshall
juve called books the gem perhaps  they
compete are the diva a valpe who
compete and that there are 6 union
pulled and i know that enough the pandemic
the european union visit new states
tip perhaps dispersed the taken after ge2
mav beyond the way male brains
breathed were like  month cacophony
almost at the key to the people of his
ninth turi asleep right are top or my
line and luis a tutu if cacophony medium
called his let's test poles and 107 tub
new on the flag open validation
of the result  or not earthquake off and here not in
round and if tasini and European food massive
solidoro csic them in kinsale highly
indicated that they are transvestites and
Chinese by john cena charity
the basic idea is that his
motor problem gene facilitate deaf v the
commission has  long tail world in v.le
lago fava members and stones one of those
stocks are available yes it is com lat mons
a valide this its set pistol all in
the puzzle 70 73 so a man and know how
survived what affection it is a
page in physics easton  we have come to
versailles fight the little genius if
thank you honorable campominosi two minutes
for you please marco i
have to start with a note i
have to mention you in july you said it is a
virus to keep at bay and they were referring
to my party to my political group
here maybe  in the enthusiasm of his new
role he could allow himself to joke
about a theme that today instead the one
relating to the problems that a virus can cause
is bringing us but because I quote
this sentence of his not to attack him  a but
to make you understand how much in a process
like the one that has been happening in recent
weeks it is very important to accept the
contribution of all of us has for several
months as Italians that we have been pointing out the
seriousness of a situation that was
happening many minimized I
represent a party that here at
opposition in rome the opposition but
the government precisely in those regions that were the
first in europe to have had this
attack so i know very well the
situation of people close to me too
who are in a serious situation in
hospital today in spain in france
let's see a  similar situation and the
measures that Italy has adopted
involving the majority and the opposition
in a debate that is often harsh and
hard God forbid they must here is the
method of involving the
opposition must also involve Brussels at the
level because in any case I am
not speaking on my behalf  and only of my
group I speak also on behalf of
representatives and in the institutions at the
level  therefore they represent us
when we had proposals to
improve today's texts yes we
reduced them to a minimum
in the end but they were needed precisely
so that a
clearer and more complete resolution of these problems could be reached
I know that the European Commission has offered
an interpretation the  as flexible as
possible I know that the regions of northern
Italy who have asked for
the intervention to be more incisive have
been given reassurances but here
with regard to the political issue the problem is that of
rules which were at the basis of
your European construction which are
coming to a  a schengen road stability pact
legislation on state aid
of the same globalization which today is
in crisis today we discover that we do not know
and can no longer produce certain certain
things that are essential for our
health therefore what is happening
in italy is very great there are  companies
that are converting their
production to be able to supply i
our hospitals
there are countries that are enemies of
our institution russia china cuba the
united states that are helping italy
if a response comes from
europe it is welcome but certain conditionalities
provided for by the mes make no sense and
mean that we are unaware  of the
fact that Italy, when there was a
need to help other countries,
paid 60 billion over the various years
what we got in return from the
commission between 2011 and 2018 are 63
requests to the member states to
cut healthcare and privatize it, that's it  it's
time to change all this thank
you mrs g to basque please one minute and 30 for you can enjoy voice micro-enterprises given a kiss friend you call rich hunk chants Europeans ski team yes tucci
cartubi government pro crisis split the
sexy ex empty acsi a national stock exchange
by jared azimuth brands and
exercised g times lying the usual
gras some beautiful casetti
national brands vo boars up saturated and  your
own transporter move the
problems of the lot of problems
music you will have majestic rasmus gypsies
would have if policy stego of mister
cretu sorci christ theists to annoy but
it's always two partners crisis if onerous mi
hop the company and no and said not estonian
missini i would have  men in her who practices
in the q no tell me
here jerky we use products from same
goes between goes from self our v ed in house
pazar buy area products votes
created by tarabotti prostheses then
done by transport couples
soon berna short stay healed wait
81 entrance does not open the means the
docks scenic enterprises trust kato
plus born desperate send them you will
excuse me if who of the superhit apothecaries
yesterday saw a ride on occ no births
revealed the victims youtube of yes
but me stopped with risks merck no
let's try his transport to brighter enagas
to the mobius package casa the go and
comforting the coach to expensive because
now taken perhaps in cuba iacovone
lisbon i  n itis to see the show
fresh flowers woods i.e. scripts and cantatas it is
called that it is whole that it has created
sentences the sinking external of the group
while lizza the coats in cat and risks
of the park in the juice it is touched by said
who tyner real idea package a
often system the brands we will know stuffed with
real fees of the stands of the stands
harmony us to the list and poses what
burdens today to be expected brands the stop is
squeezed he loves me my economic dema but of
magni sturbo magazine.it and perhaps the
faults ischetus in  autonomy apologies to
taste luca cassettes to sagat and for
mobius packages sega gil evans senate
exams we are slow in responses an era
botti bros directors cirica the choir athena
trout created dock rosinés abyen
mason bar curva veron the themes si tosi
speculative in da nec  then create utic a
man the kits and they gave him to benches samus
vulgar fake sad to serve a and
bruno cousin iss campesi period states
economic cantù powerscan a buckets and a
grape  economic wrecks find brands
of all the tvs a grotesque how
best of lightning in weight strongly
bishop we will have the good enough
bureaucratic separate interest remains the
right you see you swaggers present
his who comes to moussavi theses low taste i
have to keep my box ib safe
thanks  honorable honorable bo
please hold a minute the garrison yes to
the european commission
where goods and people the ster it and see
the cleaner public health or use of
that diesel and on new complément the
shortcut of the paschi a pazzelli passe
breathed two males ss in marches
low ios wounds and you know he's getting married his ends
he defined smog
nicolò fonda with steve garrington of
decree 26 water right watch click on a
file system works spa ring funds
thanks honorable muresan please three
minutes for you
collins solid solidarity is done with
hardship weekend  of this day by day may
day one in four immediate by colin
morgan and del budget the circle the
european commission moby  lines
this wide web tv budget happy
concludes collins john hopkins traveling
jamie hince meeting people you rock my
thing you can't we 0 klinsmann in europe
business ning pipoli rodney king in
blazing in chad is on pole day to be able
to beat closed exposed winning  time
out
honorable markers please 2 minutes and 30
please prey
yes Mr. President and whoever is in
the European Parliament ready and trouble
the axes say through the crisis out of
7 think often pagan anxiety agora never
relief mini mic silent tac
the first repower thanks year pros milan
suffers ipra on extremes where the press
imprò 0 the fc protects our
south our feeds tod's of durant este crisis
cleaning physx system
protest constipation an apple unit from sleuth tastes
august at home then it was always breaking
rain brake stand by but then a  rome
interesting business is correct and
assure us michael I know that
a crisis film can work in trans sport
even if tourists spend to travel
mentalit  à European I go out and correct
the purists grease arf 10 weights solidarity
house painters set hans ruesch i 3 1 but
then space can't be from saxon
singh
the answer thanks airconsult the kurds
nada the shockers for who or three parties
and franchises and in particular style
margin ars and mental studies give and
from europe and you don't have a chris wood with
westwood ems the fans comark room eyes
europe you exist you instance europeans
the defender mutu explodes you can hear bolgi flowing
yes samsung always political sisal
sterpaia broom crisis fortwo  virus not
therefore ex front either news always cup
lucra European answers are used pre
more spacey downs mountain cliff
its fleurs du mal o the cure nostri a 6 table will
impose screech within crew
funding transposed crisis but not sir
ken adam learn so we risk decade
and psi  smile padovese ex isi v
but if transmission from points that montani
and to the institution the pooh lithium yes full of
always wise yes they are answers sense taggi
the power of attorney does not co  nsunta gore and puri on
etsy stuarda clean commented to
turn maestro curi mais with fiat in the
horns and use it instrument lfi skies
always spurned guard enterprises
in prims innovations stess then hartford
extraordinary stand of goods his
sinister minutes and suspense on always
gaggi disk menstyle apoyar  yesui sanif
in the public a great plan discs
while europa closed cones and cones and
cones and pisa ifc are rendered cells or far
europe even spurs the man
who killed north east and chris will transform
europe our fides both from moore era
still passes chance scuti  the ispra heads
to spend time they are maxine cruise
lines maison because breeders very
fast and to send software i hope ours
always knows how to take risks in knowing schools
maintain prices
i hope it was in third hood troubled
live in female the services beefy
rus produced returns enemy pro bushy raf
eros  sol de then take a look at several examples of
jean a top of the range mr pislaru
please a minute  and thirty
are not the sockets of interest solid
racz colleges
your aunt in the outdoor area in a response putelli
solid decisive to the european union
just crisà pandemic covino species head
capacity flexibility tahuni neither europeans
nor da responds as on the urgent care
save eservices shiloh credem un asta
snai stairs last a test linked
in the summer public pac socioeconomic
aster and steps lattes european spirit
fiber our social we have land
black grapes national civil society decision
makers the european level top ten
eligible candidates demaj a lot of solidarity german crete
force real has spirit  licia values
their pains at a the fullbacks diversity the
nivelle european focus deja a look
loves him lessor c7 of billions of euros for
initiative pentri invested was expelled
the colonist trust mixed in background
alone and help aluminum european csbc
treves we expose to me not the  he would have
ensured kacie station the certainty
that acceptances would benefit from the
country pre nori mentioned categories
binders a to make records inclusions
professionals independence angel and
offers us services benefited from profit-making
clan gallazzi chipata and categories
gangs agis depression busy people luca
talk with own look at hours in
agriculture zyl year benefited from
certain profits that deny stabilo krazia skis
blocked and  financiar and the nivel european
solidarity publications spezzine
responsible make people
vulnerable in access and sperlinga xena
the nivelle member state and bros nuit chez
mai then the hiatus to our
civil society or angel lecce justine is strong
in our pin campani of these totti
in  tense municipalities and solos cit create
a European solidarity fund inside
ranger now ferrara finance prev
taylor
then there's you climb to the European level
not least real estate mobilize
Europe wholeheartedly nor solidarity the care
these are at the forefront there  it will be
attacks values ​​europe nor suffer
team blue hope sankei full
transmits with dall to
nsia partially a marshall news group
families victim and the goddess transmitting
knowledge profited your knees treated
volunteer dorin tutor power for time
mind le greece flight but with three one
shadows came out a thank you honorable uta sari
please two minutes
but hellman polo village pandemic and it
by rockstar
exact closing courteline crazy
rus 2 tower yuan if you have it towers
coincide study torio in casale enamels
ota alone europe alone called
martelive o and michael nyman historias
thorium lux.mi net in
styron pasteur head spurs tyrone expensive o  no
in full a thousand timber you us who
wrote the nanny normal countries in paideia
rest if you want tav asti theme
coronavirus line maria at the bare euro
crisis closing institutions choice and pop and even
reality marion rock the tam tam ethan
hawke and us o late months  and eva with
steven kane ott
pallotto the oppo history mom knows more
psyche currency unions and iole more seenet and
i heads the husband bouty gold in cannes
beta i  husband walter group bhutan
orona good arouses tata crisis ei socar
warts nas the tanit of mister m nymph
us the right euros i'm layton and the mail
and you ilte in the faces ovar to the ministries
me le toux us who wrote currencies
or mixed with slis  he told me but it they
make the full-back the stands hours and
you are either the new mothers woman etienne vita
and the mothers lan intact a pilot and a
red elisa kollektiv detach mi
scaglio country in crisis also megawatt
line and never nice poem help us  with
word exit mechanisms euro euro pasta
checks carried out oct was then omar i
evaluated the nile that in the age never euro and
the sobi but is ripe the manners the net
fine meters to the caen papalis mixed with sal
list honeys sit'n'go over bend
the isvap institute i maintain costs or
maicon sully sam and tools polka dot the east if
honorable van over welte please ion also
the president colegas the chimneys sandri
with tunnel matt made in china european
well period nitsch and pavia english
very old terr  and and from me because peter
forster marvel i produce order making
passive holding ruby
i hope
inconvenience first or krupp or another studio
athos sociale economies the it will have
android jobs the red om kraft intact out
of home a car secret free on by
thor 3d evening on the  smart card dead set
candellero european boot pensions winston
with administrative studs jeter internal
if in the best buy and or maxi mauro
flexibility protected national
initiatives
out of tinet miss oh billions of islam
you have in the the undertaker stubbs with
great linger hofer group stick that was
east  del billion clothing and end o
a big ling maximal flexible and band
bar new design come trough the big
ardesis crisis and now we go for fun
daisy crisis of cellophane paper tiger
on a trip contingency plan for the city
steps motel colleague stop shopping o
krupp maximal dring  candesi crisis and marc
forster and ausl atam tekken android
programming lost year of the green di
textures words that robbi  and keane yes
priority both yes thanks
honorable and wallace please a minute peace
president malika staff or password
bindi virus from sky sport cobis the small
fund europe inc nation marlies schild
munster leinster team belen
questo announcement line italy fair the people
we can see honorable caspari  2 minutes and
30 for her
secret
a global pandemic accomplices out but
I think she sells kebabs tugging and she
makes me think same feeling sources melt
that I think they are already deputy profile
families but checking sad because
at global I leaf through a truck driver
but one hand  national and global to madame
pesc who eats more they try to copy on
solidarity and elkan nationalism 20
hourglass talks then an experience in 66
kg half our dental opinion
sachs this limit not on its own
company nietas demand welcome the fact
union on mini foreigner duct also
command  flag a nis has on average it went
to basket or fispic family fish disasters
vogel ben paz  iente nos
italian american stars on 20th king is
taking care colleagues not connected to the
bar fan forum stand thanks
honorable pq please tonino 2 minutes and
30 thanks present with the sima where
arise radi li na o 21st dhabi carlos
ski parliament fire limits were in
ten  tanasov rais quote succeeds
first thriller if you are
billions of euros a raspolo civic a boss b
if humans the old ones pandemic coronavirus
anas between generic viagra getting married mars
for vizzini moral vitis austaliani
siren virus holiness votes us to be able to
play lupe then give a sentence
rescue hyseni on naba can premise
thriller if you celery your lungs a
euroscapes phoenixes mind i received
generates of tina prona the cunning
later in the evening of i took every kills them
doctors excavation presses new industry
strategy dark insured strate
shake new year euro  scania or cito for
wordpress new circuses but only newlyweds
dude for chris and bici smatko old
crisis and dt success of pri  me animaux
now cene alexia morozzi glaciers anna
laganà you blasi but then yes from cesana you
grow gianni and scoop in itself or for hyper v
heart could suppositories in my surrender
evenings i got sick microbe duse heaven do
n't keep euro you can get married the clapperboard must
be post  a drug instead the slovenian
posi di zama garnier tourist crisis fox i
see some neurosis pro race a
celani known car tubs share voice
pie for now there is a waitress at the first
picture tourism a tourist a poor man and
sector and pop first thing then
prior that I take from you purple the real
okaz remained 1 ter fondazza ribarski be
able to susa spaces treebar history here
culture safe radio abstract nyan oscar
ocher pro and goes or ismar and a
dark program and sixteen cups start wiesmann
mother-in-law stop and del set billion euros
and take action to doda the pesto billion
wishes to stabilize purpose mechanisms
I underwent three demonstrations made me
assured and minimal but gifts but then
there's used for waste but the appropriate
guarantees on males potec homenaje of in
an idiot
luciano but there is structure nico
kaziyski fund vvv ex suffer them and damage
closure ianni who invested aunt in car from
nalut body of the dark efforts to the new
for the topic both life and strategists
eurocqs and unisa subbiano  pandemic cota
strategy neither unofficial in misano balkan on the
side then sermon modo cucco I sit down
after the packages snap homo citran stan
unjust remained jersey know balkan in
brienno street and silky million and now
use a leases store sedan gave
3 thousand a eurasia drew strange a with a
shotgun now they look at it that finances ski
promo it seems to us marco example pismo
first from his own or cruz and in the south my
march the nation or you politicians boss
luca here gorio woodson rape if i know
cyrene the top teams fall on evening a
stain doni galvan iacona alone  doble
on the same pocetta please war but it
creates illusions misa qualities in short
this can mobile stop with the degree
festivals v but armor you could a medium
i you  schi first bomb exhibition and crisis
your solidarity today ii naples
wells atic hake will discover stimuli and
him in digne new satin cito sti in
liguria less in just dinasty which thanks
thanks
honorable inter health please sofia one
minute and 30 of the media
the ex  great honorable in two minutes
in functions they were in function anti
nationalist svan di needles or between via
action ghezzal cosmogenesis val di
exercises and in italy the art form to
finance the national
team a team of dragons from ken well-known
political bloggers or you fall to the lands  today had
data are shutdown not beta does programs
launched by davis concrete expanses
goodie is stevenage's fat iggy has
viewed with faith politics or dialogues and
scenes
does not offer planking please minute the 30
round of cup len from on science and at
solid network sale  as spec in the ex
with lance a film doesn't end and you think
doc baiardo forum is incomplete missing
xhixha diesel ex to you to adjust
a task from our hunt with of lim
locates  tion in europe or abandoned of
scam besana via kahn do instead of
thanks mr dorfman please herbert
two minutes get up and president colleagues
not colleagues like italian blunt
often jokes from the cross-country skier asked tesco
bulldozers tronista mitigate discuss spy
fighter the mustang neuro fish but
this morning i said that  if you waste not
if you want to compare carpi schoensberg who
said he is always off line europeans jean
claude o di gavi dimensional of europeans
jean todt righthaven xp oct well
stability on get it states a cinisi
material chez maxim's samsung hardening
ukrainians on ten contested networks saman
fang  air the pes rais also finance can
see what's fan under the same dir sfop
in dancing art marcum supervision and
young rider thrifty sinister is
deployed avoid hyenas region contains
tyler pesceni on this state really
shell same ramones stone faced
in migration that stood out taider
union  of outcome ass
mauro fish on wright former pilot conti
ten che  my banner staff thank
made man singh now indies the region
in the italian shoes mitm around said
mensch they didn't think of
regional money in the sense of stalin dress
onyx suit but it is understood at the bottom
nyon taxi drivers
the extended cakes thoughts between nyon
selfridges  existential holidays in
politicians and take a linguistic test and brown
has in itself neither commissions nor
talks niche gere enel.si visions
why not waiting by tightening it of the
knicks internet does the purpose posters
prints of cannes in green deal brawn the
team penning defant volkstaat cipe panis
of  print dpa several layers of many
opinions titanbet data center smart
discounted but now stardom china the
extras martino
stent's club comes the sound of kain
often honorable moretti please
alessandra 2 minutes and 30 the
coronavirus pandemic and a human tragedy of
potentially biblical proportions after
many years of peace and progress
social welfare europe is experiencing a
nu phenomenon  dangerous egg with dramatic consequences
the coronavirus knows no borders or
social class it affects misery and
nobility alike and no one will
emerge stronger than the others no one
will save themselves
we are at war it is a war that requires
collective mobilization and that is
why it appears today  it is urgent to
reform Europe to make it truly a
United States of Europe according to the plan
of the founding fathers
we can no longer tolerate the selfishness of
some we will emerge from this crisis only
if united and in solidarity and if Europe
leads the strategies to be adopted
Italy was the first European country
to face the emergency and I know you
can understand my emotion to speak
today in this hall to speak proudly
of my country which has
become a model for all the other
countries,
I say it with  imprinted in the heart in the
mind the number of deaths that
grows every day and then we cannot fail to
thank doctors nurses
health workers  he police forces and all the
workers in the supply chain of
essential goods who continue to go to
work
the hauliers who
deliver the goods amidst a thousand
difficulties and obstacles this cursed
virus has highlighted in all its
force the fragility of a Europe of
nationalisms where all the governments
more or less in the last 40 years have
cut resources on strategic sectors
such as research and healthcare, not knowing
today how to guarantee the safety of doctors
in the ward
a Europe that has not been able to create
a consortium on vaccine research
then and  now
that we have to treasure the mistakes
made mario draghi a great Italian
a great European it is no coincidence that yesterday on the
eve of such an
important day he warned the European states
with these words in this crisis
a change of mentality is necessary as
in times of war
the  shock we are facing is not
cyclical the loss of income is
nobody's fault  those who suffer from it
the cost of hesitation may be
irreversible it does not exist do not hesitate
states dragons tell us because an
exceptional crisis requires exceptional
and immediate measures
so many resources so much liquidity to
mobilize avoiding bureaucratic delays
because it is our political and moral duty to
save businesses and jobs  families
this must be our obsession
colleagues do not be cowardly do not be
modest national governments because in
doing so you fall into the trap of
sovereignists who want a weak Europe
afraid and not up to a global challenge I
conclude by saying that this is the time for
courage not for  shyness and
hypocrisy for all national governments
for majorities and oppositions
all none excluded
thank you thank you honorable cani as please one
minute and thirty in the head student from
michele will remain at the tear of the
same this parliament for premier us
this is full
while a moment soy who  a thousand
Europeans arose  in mind life
and death in hospital unglued with
basic facts and materials that with a
sloppy professionalism that separate
life to share has been reconfirmed
while if a moment sacks million zero
for strange confined to sky transform
after the sos with us sales that  close to
mito perverse knows that i scheme arrays
of not being able to carry it out for
in the experience of the os in while vattimo
knows who hears a thousand always because they
will always assume saas autonomous deva
tensor they go to be able to serve or they go
to keep you in ferrara and experience on
road in favor of a
terrible situation but also graft the
moment I'm dark from commented demos
vattimo knows who is not challenge us if it
shows great value that form same
site is not company now
generosity and compromise is the usual
returned sms with text of  compromise
that in skiing from i solieri from the chain
that gear our uncomfortable decision
signed now that we are and no
time or add  rave the moment the great
moment arouse the high ground from which
our society now I do not tremble a curno
asparano they challenge our parabitano
attenuate it inframed ato1 aspar is vital
infection our economy but yes
we have been trying medicines who
live in the noir for some time its leavening effect
asks study those who know our
economy de study businesses gameplay the
challenge greets school as a sum in the
good direction is showing and fission
sky was our health system
the emotions mechanism sky will
allow our country will finally be absent
the crisis due to
insufficient mosques  mass ians who
serve inter because fate sanfront amos
and yes the sion network if it's going to turn into
a depression
i'm in his private but the decision
goes to inter
the firmware challenge i
'm sorry studied a word a
concept that the transfer  of the smi lot
that was henry and moral the moral hazard
we hold sacred face each other
obsessive ac voice  hara carso vernoux
estate spal from left with fintia
death non store they gave themselves the
moral hazard must make miller die semper
sas the moral laughter of the farc that
millions if the boundless explains on the play
and if it would be theron i succeed moral to
which no  listen musical that we intend to
challenge solutions to finalize that
you have to nostrano farmers h it is clear that they
go without having to possible the boss the
par asked don't pass because no
affaire rossi I didn't run away from the
clear tear that they don't study slow stan
alone and who is left crisis smaghi  and if it goes to
pedara trash and you're viruses not only
will they be massacres life on our simple
on our future
don't be hopeful until I've
infected lethally I don't get scratched
and I didn't want it screens say it and I
passed we spun off that it comes
off masters
that only the  debts and that strong than
necessary our site lanus and if they will be st
compromise cattesco 7 thanks honorable
st group please a minute
ma cruda e sama canada o stelle rummage
gam r old sibility will spend history
of baseball yacht with who died
install in the 100m and well but this was
then between three cars stefan pulls from such
from stop and do chordis fort de france of
20 of the stages  with it cancel well written
if or the day the flag in dog colors
rebecca hall indro nicotera had made herself
of deserts in numb efficient thanks
honorable sbai please two minutes the
presidency committed by colleagues of
ethnic solidarity directed the
outerwear principal disk via pio xi
presents willing of art of circle of
canada and solidarity on tv or in
situation and asked to give her and summer
fils to design patient hayden
fantasyland killing the view is
disregarded thanks honorable item please one
minute and thirty
indeed bank president and deputy fish nylon
a provocateur  slave passion
zancan puts 9 i get an idea state and goliath a
since away as mayor i have a crisis
flow a passage from frings new
state with the going es  cloth t liang
and i did it with this sport ramat
migron hands out but remains a tender break
hard disk in and show how you never know
noses string darling of credits and studio
jean moment problems will
also be staged ford mustang package for  who
is more to him analysts drawer
but the thing does not go with patron full
crisis of conakry science fest of banana
democratic change joke but steve
martin and president of hera the last
speaker now the reply of the
commission the floor to commissioner
sefcovic please mark maros
dear president you when i read members
stauder openparliament buy goes by
expressing be clear solidary solidarity
you or i.e. in the stupendous terrible god and
in the south hall like to express but
gratitude south heroes of the day the
doctors doctor profession others stand
formed spa dal soft the police source
fools paris and people who are
working in decrees clarence celibi che
tale work from hell lights and the
european parliament
or look at  back josh howard blue
king tape of working stations una
pace sitting at work by this new way of
first votes extreme reporter sens single
european citizens workers so much from
difficulty conditions and weekend and no
car ed of the decision success rustle
ford power citizens are like also  to
thank mister gonzalez pons moreno
sanchez but from a dell'ang mister
benifei work realizing di gaiarine completely
news set up and t in the european
commission e l'
idv atlus mayor lo scoprì show with you to
find the best responses for this
previous situation room  east bay and mi
internship male v6 the fog water rats
lucchino a we are all right thing that
virili modo lightworks customers found
the way out best shirow responsibility
smi so un egg debris 6 sebadoh
responsibility for the rights act to
doctors glen game ris is  not about
shifting all of the manager of pg
simply art work to get enough of the plis
dolls hold and predominant in the
discussion of today is the w  eek end to
death android dear gearing same écoles
coming from our members themselves
a a like to run shore mister bo tenga
moto for act able difficulty with
stan sis ace lights to what it takes
fronts situation strong walking with
chris madame aubry is miss moore  e ciano
asking for the cosby art fall and rising
true grit myers weekend of operation
weekend and leave her and cooperation
dei lupi e nero prima results of the
match ball concrete of sky map out romanian
male sheep concluded but you can breathe
weekly foretz remain good music  event
in town again and very strong di sky
sport
cruz technology from the crisis and
death in venice days
ore di medico the millennium non si
vince b under our jurisd usual not be
of this the member states to fly di
script man husband di howl decision to
see plies zeus dos member states where
seven days of demos and nye thing by
heidi a smara mean that was suggesting
su vinit by strategic research for
sensitive equipment for the f  eature iv
reboot neri too vedesse house and
current situation via working on and
tools trans of working on economic
aspects think before you man city
predominant doctor yesterday depends
positive impulses reform il vero corsini tute
macroeconomics in liquids tifo lauro
finance systems and to rispondimi
boot not for  banks bat world business
ford is semi operations of two protected
job silicosi are full wet jobs steve
jobs di cosa of corona corona vyrus
crysis
semper love you man falls bazooka of
european central bank ag ed ex addition
to be lin euro without ad program or
easybits go  together response castrum i
cibo in once we were kingery closely
with a e b and thanks to power finance
contribution ii bis developing the
program world of two madrid buy and hold
on space and ed è sam is because we're
not the main employer in the european
union  and deal of course looking into
the voice of two of the big
kinda street fi mail use this opportunity
to go on t  he garments in senso gli stand
i love you think you the european
commission to develop dei crisis skins
us the country ceiling wise tenerde salede
ore di live done and vigilant in express
man thanks to the great words of vice
president back stage e plus s league lo
stage
en v disc assist a un ode to develop
the program di skins gara di youtube in
the european commission is live that also
be carlo while days countries with
cantù last week end together di valon
recava replace vvd need it for kids
every single member states concerning
the vax insen en en concerning e corona
vyrus responsi systems in o degli ore di
halo get it while tom sachs henshaw
samsung hands enrico berlinguer closely
dei special adviser walking
without president's group was there di pepi
epidemiologists sta ma ero logis all
blogs the buck shroud  via red a ready
to make sure that would protect our
critical industry and in the times stock
exchange roxster watch could be faceted
is mail for t  e coms p simply won't let
it happen believe the european
parliament cosi
in jazz e forza a few weeks rubber
lasting intervention in december
watson martini of science of the great
total pink budget finite seven years
finance software spect xo weekend plan
caveri uv robert eco  bag emergency soft
dei i've just rima general public
intact full of garin last year of the
seven years budget and we are very much
limited wine and finance o constant
soubrette video conference of the
leaders disastri in 11 b focus nacher
lei one technic corona vhils  but also be
the king and desires economic front in
final four bet finiti mfn oldies prices
sul make it christ that the leader stage
in it could progress on that levo the
film you conclude these pristina youth
conclude de pong beach made by
madame according to the mayors  gli strip pisticci
nas del the best responses to the post
crisis development work with that you're
in the crisis of course on the daily
management out to make y  ou victims of
the same time it in what would be the
change and all his new europe
technological autonomy strategic sovereign
t a nobody the msi stock exchange european
commission
mister president thank you for coming
workforce sport tnas from your the
working station sang soo interpreters
technician possible thanks  thanks to
vice president sefcovic and
our debate ends here before announcing the
results of the votes let me greet
with you our colleagues our
colleagues who are connected via
streaming with the classroom and who have
participated in the first votes even
with a little emotion  that I say this
because it is the first time that a
democratic parliament has used a method of
remote participation
it had never happened before it fell to
the European Parliament to experience this
in a period of great emergency
for the life of our citizens
I am very grateful to the political groups  to
all political groups for
strongly supporting the idea that  the
parliament must continue to
function
we need the parliament we
cannot interrupt the
democratic process of the european union we have
so many answers to give to our
citizens right now and we must of
course feel
responsible for it we have a duty that is why i
am also very grateful to all  the
parliamentary structures that have
done a great job in recent weeks to allow
our colleagues
to be able to participate in this
extraordinary plenary today using
unprecedented methodologies never used before
687 parliamentarians took part in the vote
and I think this is an
extraordinary result
for  regarding the results on the
requests for urgent procedure
regarding the allocation of
slots in the airports of the community
common standards votes cast 687 votes in
favor 687 second vote on the
specific measures aimed at mobilizing the
investments in the health systems of the
member states and other sectors of
their with economy and response
to the covit epidemic 19 votes cast 687
votes in favor and 686 votes against 1
abstentions 0 the request for
urgent procedure and therefore approved on the
third vote financial assistance
to member states countries  who are
negotiating accession to the European Union
heavily affected by the serious
public health emergency votes
cast 687 votes in favor
684 votes against 1 abstentions 2
the request for urgent procedure and
therefore approved
thank you all for your patience with the
discipline that all  Members of parliament
are putting into this test that
concerns us but above all the answer
that we will be able to give to our citizens
now the deadlines for
the presentation of the amendments on
in the other votes are
the presentation of the amendments the
deadline set at 2.00 pm
the deadline for the presentation
requests for votes for
separate or separate parties to  4.00 pm and for the
moment the sitting is suspended until 5.30 pm
I thank you and above all thank you
for your cooperation, thank you
[Applause]
[Music]